[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى الخامسه نناقش فيها ونقدم
تفاصيل مجموعه من الملفات وهذه العناوين
[موسيقى]
بوتين يتوعد الناتو ردا على اسلحته
لاوكرانيا والدفاع الروسيات تقيم
التهديدات الغربيه
[موسيقى]
مقتل المستوطنين اثنين في نابلس بالتزامن
مع اجتماع العقبه الخاص بخفض التصعيد
في ايران العمله المحليه تسجل الانخفاضات
قياسيا جديدا وغضب عملي يتصاعد تنديدا
بتدني الاجور
[تصفيق]
ظهور جديد لابنه زعيم الكوريه الشمالي
برفقه والدها وسط انباء عن دور مستقبلي
لها في السلطه
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى التفاصيل سنبداها من
تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا والتي دخلت
عامها الثاني قبل يومين حيث شن الرئيس
روسيا فلاديمير بوتين هجوم جديدا على
الغرب متهما اياه بمحاوله التصفيه بلاده
واشار بوتين الى ان الغرب يريد تصفيه
روسيا وتقسيمها الى دويلات يسهل السيطره
او يسهل السيطره عليها بوتين تهم الغرب
وزراعه حلف الناتو بانه شريك غير مباشر في
جرائم ارتكبتها اوكرانيا من خلال الاصرار
على ارسال الاسلحه فيما شدد بوتين على
ضروره ان تاخذ موسكو في الاعتبار القدرات
النوويه لحلف الناتو واعلن بوتين ان بلاده
لا تعارض مشاركه دول الناتو في مناقشه
وبحث معاهده نيو ستارت النوويه التي اعلنت
موسكو مؤخرا تعليقا العمل بها مشددا على
ضروره وضع القدرات النوويه لفرنسا
وبريطانيا تحت الرقابه في اي اتفاق
مستقبلي في هذه الاثناء قال وزير الدفاع
الروسي قال ان المدى الذي ستضطر معه روسيا
الى الدفاع عن حدودها ستحدده شحناته
الاسلحه الغربيه التي يتم توريدها الى
اوكرانيا واضاف شيغو ان روسيا لن تتراجع
عن تنفيذ اهدافها من العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا لحمايه حدود البلاد من اي تهديد
في غضون ذلك دفعت موسكو عن تعليق مشاركتها
في معاهده نيو ستارت النوويه وقال رئيس
جهاز الاستخبارات الخارجيه الروسيه ناري
شكينا قال ان القرار كان بمثابه مفاجاه
للغرب لكنه اكد انه كان منطقيا
نتابع هذا الموضوع مع زمينا من موسكو
مراسله العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد عبد
الجواد اهلا بك معنا اولا تصريحات بوتين
في اي اطار نضعها هل هي مقابله وهل تسرب
شيء اخر عما قال بخصوص هجومه عن الغرب
او على الغرب
مرحبا نعم ريم مرحبا نعم بالفعل يعني
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين خرج اليوم
للحديث عن الاستراتيجيه وعن السلاح
الاستراتيجي في العالم من قبل موسكو من
جهه ومن قبل الجانب الغربي من من جهه اخرى
بوتين طبعا في بدايه حديثه تحدث عن ضروره
التقييم الصحيح لموسكو للوضع ووضع السلاح
النووي الاستراتيجي لدى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولد حلف الناتو هي رسائل طبعا
تحدث بها بوتين لكن لابد من لفت الانتباه
بان خطاب بوتين دوما هو صريح يعني والشعب
والمجتمع الروسي متعود على تقبل كلماته
كما يقولها لذلك طبعا الخطاب كما قرئ
سياسيا في البلاد كما سمعه الشارع الروسي
يتحدث عن ان موسكو تمد يدها لطاوله الحوار
من جديد لكن مع الابقاء على يعني قوه
الرضع في حال تعرض الدخل الروسي او تعرضت
روسيه لضربات او تم يعني تزويد نظام كييف
باسلحه بعيده المدى او مقاتلات يمكنها
الوصول نحو مناطق روسيه في الداخل او شبه
جزيره القرن يعني الموضوع طبعا هو
المره الاولى التي
ليست المره الاولى يتحدث فيها بهذه
الطريقه عن الغرب ولكن كانت له كذلك
تصريحات اخرى وهنا الجديد في الموضوع
بوتين فتح امكانيه ان يشارك الناتو في
مناقشه نيو ستارت بعد ان علقت روسيا او
على الاقل انسحبت منها مؤخرا هذا ما قالته
روسيا الرسميه كيف تعاملت وكيف تفاعلت
الاوساط السياسيه الروسيه مع هذا التصريح
يعني هذا التصريح يدل ريم حول الاوساط
الاوساط السياسيه في البلاد يعني يتحدث
حول ان موسكو في حال رغبت بمناقشه القوه
النوويه الغربيه لابد لها من حسابات ما
تملكه لندن وما تملكه باريس وما يملكه حلف
الناتو بشكل كلي طبعا لا يخفى على احد بان
فرنسا وبريطانيا وحدها تملك قرابه 600
طبعا صاروخ استراتيجي لذلك طبعا لابد من
الاخذ بعين الاعتبار هذا الحجم الكبير
طبعا الاتفاق بين موسكو واشنطن بما يخص
بما يخص ستار نيو هو معروف وجميع بنوده
متاحه للجميع لكن طبعا لم يؤخذ فيها حساب
ما يملكه لذلك طبعا موسكو تتحدث اليوم من
جديد عن ضروره معرفه وحساب القدرات
الغربيه في هذا الموضوع لذلك طبعا موسكو
علقت العمل في اتفاقيه ستارت طبعا لا يخفى
على احد بان دخول العامل الصيني على
المواجهه وعلى طرح الفكره التي قد توصل
بالجميع الى طاوله الحوار يلعب دورا
محوريا بهذا الموضوع هي مرحله لعدد
الاصابع يراها البعض ريم لرفع سقف
المطالبات على ما يبدو ان الزياره الصينيه
الاخيره لموسكو قد يتبعها زيارات صينيه
الى الى
عقد لقاءات مع الرئيس الاوكراني
مع الجانب الصيني قد تثمر عبر حوار لكن
النقطه الاساسيه التي اجتمع عليها
المحللون السياسيون اليوم في البلاد
والقراءه العسكريه بانه حتى هذه اللحظه
كيف قرارها ليس مستقل وهي عباره عن قطعه
على لوحه الشطرنج الكبيره التي يلعب بها
الغرب هذا ما تحدث عنه السياسيون في
البلاد اليوم سيبقى موضوعا للمتابعه شكرا
جزيلا لك عبد الجواد الرشد مراسل العربيه
من موسكو
قبل المتابعه نشير الى هذا العاجل مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي يقول ان الصين لم
تاخذ قرارا نهائيا بشان مساعده روسيا
موضوع
سنستكمله بما سبق من تطورات فحول خطه
الصين للسلام في اوكرانيا ابدا وزير
الدفاع الالماني بوريس بيستوريوس تشككا
اذا الخطه لوقف اطلاق النار في اوكرانيا
وقال وزير الدفاع الالماني في مقابله
صحفيه ان طرحه خطه السلام الصينيه
بالتزامن مع التقارير بان بيكين تخطط
لامداد روسيا بطائرات المسيره الانتحاريه
يؤكد ضروره الحكم على موقف الصين بافعالها
لا باقوالها
وسط احتدام المعارك على الارض في دنياتك
نشرات وكاله الاعلام الروسيه مقطع فيديو
تم التقاطه بطائره بدون طيار اظهر حجم
الدمار والاضرار الجسيمه في مدينه التي
تشهد معارك عنيفه بين الجيش الروسي
والاوكراني منذ اشهر متابع
[موسيقى]
استكمالا لنفس العاجل الذي كنا اوردناه
منذ قليل هناك حديث كذلك عن ان الصين اذا
فعلا ارادت ان تساعد موسكو فانها او عواقب
ذلك ستكون وخيمه بحسب مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي اذا سنتابع دائما وتبقى العين
على هذه العواجل ولكن نذكر بتطورات ما حدث
من قبل في مقابله خاصه للعربيه اكد الحاكم
العسكري والمدني لاقليم لوغاسك للعربيه
اكد تحرير اربع عشره منطقه سكنيه من سيطره
الروس فيما تدور معارك عنيفه على ثلاثه
محاور اخرى واعرب حاكم عن امله بوصول
الاسلحه الغربيه لشن هجوم مباغت وتحرير
الاقليم
الوضع في اقليم
حررنا اربع عشره منطقه سكنيه وهناك تصعيد
على جبهات عده لدينا ايضا ثلاثه محاور
مهمه هي بايل غورسكاو
يتصاعد فيها القتال بنسبه لروسيا انها
التجهيز الكثير من المجندين الجدد ولديها
جنود والكثير من الاليات موجهه الى خط
التماس حيث تدور معارك وعنيفه فيما تحافظ
قواتنا الدفاعيه علم واقعها ونامل وصول
الاليات الثقيله الهجوميه من حلفائنا في
الغرب لنتمكن من شن هجوم مباغت ونحرر
لوغاسك
الحاكم العسكري والمدني لاقليم لوغانسك
شدد ايضا على عدم القبول باي صيغه للسلام
مع بوتين مع بقاء اراضي لوغانسك تحت سيطره
روسيا كما قال مشيرا الى ان الاوكرانيين
يرفضون المتجره بارضهم بحسب تعبيره
روسيا الاتفاق مع بوتين لا يعني شيئا فهو
يكذب دائما وكلنا يتذكر ما قاله عن القرم
ان جيشه لا يحتلها بعدها قال ان الجيش
الروسي لم يكن هناك ابدا ثم عاد يتحدث عن
الشعور بالفخر باحتلال قواته القرم ايضا
قبل بضعه ايام بدايه غزوه لاوكرانيا سالوه
وقادته العسكريين هل ستندلع الحرب اجاب
كلهم لن تكون هناك حرب اي اتفاق مع بوتين
سيكون حبرا على ورق لانهم سيهاجموننا من
جديد ننتاجر باراضينا هذا موقف واضح من
الرئيس السيلينسكي والاوكرانيين
نبقى دائما او يبقى معنا مفرد العربيه
احمد بجاتو من خاركيف احمد اهلا بك معنا
كنا نتابع هذه المقابله واتيت فيها على
اسئله
واجابك حاكم
بامور غايه في الاهميه في الواقع لان هناك
تصريحات يؤكد من خلالها عدم
امكانيه ترك هذه الاراضي وكانه هناك شيء
يحذر وكانه هناك
محاوله لطرح فكره ان هذه المنطقه تتسلح
شيئا فشيئا وبان ما طلبوا في ما قبل
مكنتهم اياه الجهه الغربيه تؤكد لنا ذلك
احمد
نعم بالفعل يعني حاكم لوغانسك اكد لنا هذا
واثمن بصوره واضحه الجهود ودعم الذي تقدمه
البلاد الغربيه لاوكرانيا واكد ان هذا
الدعم وفر تقدما او ساهم في حدوث التقدم
الاخير
وساعد على احداث يعني يعني ان توجع القوات
الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه في كثير من
المناطق وتستعيد الكثير منها كما قال حاكم
لوغانسك لكن بصفه عامه يمكن قول ان هناك
مطالب اخرى يعني هناك حديث عن لقاء وفد
عسكري امريكي وحديث عن مطالب مزيد من
الاسلحه منها طائرات هذه الطبع مطالبات لا
يمكن لا نعرف ان كانت تتاكد ام لا او سيتم
تزويد القياده العسكريه اوكران بهذه
الاسلحه ام لا لكنهم يثمنون بصوره كبيره
الاسلحه التي تقدم اليهم لانها ساهمت
بوضوح في ما تم احرازه من تقدم لكن
يعني يبقى الوضع في بخمه ربما يحتاج الى
اكثر من اسلحه ضخمه تراها روسيا الان يعني
مساله حياه او موت بالنسبه لها تريد
السيطره عليها باي طريقه كانت لتنطلق بعد
ذلك الى باقي مناطق
الوضع فيها يعني كنت كان هناك فيديو يعرض
للدمار الذي طال هذه المدينه
المواطنون الذين او التقينا عدد من موطين
الذين هاجروا من هذه المدينه واكدوا ان
المدينه لم يعد فيها احد اطلاق المدينه
باتت مدينه فقط للمقاتلين من قبل الجانبين
هنا حيث تتواجد انت الان منذ بضعه ايام
كانت مركزا للسادات متكرره وانفجارات دامت
لفتره طويله حتى ان البعض تحدث عند مارتال
كل جوانب هذه المنطقه كيف هو الوضع في
اليوم احمد
نعم اخر كيف يعني نحن كنا في خركيف وبعد
ذلك لكن هي احد الجبهات الهامه والقويه
لانها تستهدف بصوره مستمره من قبل القوات
الروسيه والمدفعيه الروسيه التي تستهدف
هذه المنطقه لذلك هناك محاولات من قبل
القوات
نعم نحن هناك بعض العسكريين الاوكراني
يقولون ان علينا ان نتحرك من هنا ربما
الوجود هنا غير مسموح لكن دعينا يعني نكمل
هذا الحوار يعني
قوات عسكريه بصوره مستمره تتواجد تاتي الى
هذا الطريق والتعزيزات وتعزيزات من
الافراد تتواجد لتذهب الى خاركيف للتواجد
هناك لان هذه المنطقه تستهدف بصوره مستمره
هناك ايضا حديث عن ان هذه السدافات اثرت
على البنيه التحتيه بصوره كبيره خطوط
الغاز والكهرباء المواطنون يعانون بصوره
كبيره الكثير من المواطنين الذين يلتقيهم
يريدون نهايه لهذه الحرب نهايه قريبه ايا
كانت ايا كان شكل لهذه النهايه سواء
النهايه بتسويه بين
الطرفين او نهايه بارجاع كامل للاراضي
الاوكرانيه للسياده الاوكرانيه
بهذا القدر احمد
نعم رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني قال انه عندما
سئل عن مصالحه مع الروس وخصوصا مع الحديث
عن المبادرات المستمده قال انه لا يتوقع
مصالحه خلال 100 عام القادمه النظام
الروسي لن يتغير لذلك لن تكون هناك مصالحه
قريبه مع النظام الروسي نعم اود شكرا
جزيلا شكر وسلامتك احمد نلتقي في نشرات
اخرى مفرد العربيه احمد باجاتو شكرا دائما
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع فاصل مشاهدينا من بعد سنعود
لنتابع
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه تتعهد باتخاذ
اجراءات ضد الهجره غير النظاميه بعد غرق
سفينه ومسرع خمس واربعين شخصا
نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد ونستكمل نشاطنا
من ملف اخر وهو الاجتماع الذي يعقد في
الاردن للمره الاولى بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين برعايه امريكيه حيث اكدت
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه ان وفدها الذي يشارك
في الاجتماع شدد على ضروره وقف جميع
الاعمال الاحاديه الاسرائيليه واضافت
الرئاسه في بيان نقلته وكاله الانباء
الفلسطينيه ان ذلك سيسهم في خلق افق سياسي
يقوم على قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومبادره
السلام العربيه وسيعيد التاكيد على التزام
دوله فلسطين بقرارات الشرعيه الدوليه طريق
لانهاء الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وتجسيد اقامه
دوله فلسطين على حدود العام 1970
وبالتزامن مع اجتماع العقبه اكدت هيئه
الاسعاف الاسرائيليه مقتله مستوطنين اثنين
في عمليه اطلاق النار جنوبي نابلس وذكر
مراسل العربيه ان القوات الاسرائيليه
اغلقت جميع الحواجز في بلده حواره جنوبي
نابلس بحثا عن منفذ الهجوم ولم يتضح على
الفور عدد المنفذين
[موسيقى]
شكلهم اثنين ميتين واحد بنازع واحد مات
وبالعوده الى الشمال العقبه من العقبه
مراسل العربيه عماد العضايله عماد اهلا بك
معنا نتحدث عن هذا الاجتماع فماذا في جدول
اعماله وان كنا امام دائره يعني يجتمع
فيها وتجتمع فيها كل الاطراف ام نحن امام
اجتماعات ثنائيه بواسطه الجهه الامريكيه
نعم يعني لغايه هذه اللحظه لم يرشح اي
معلومات عن ما توصل لي هذا الاجتماع وهذا
اللقاء سوى ان مصدر مقرب من منا تحدثنا
معه كان قريب من هذا الاجتماع قال بان
الاجتماعي يهدف الى الوصول الى تفاهمات
والوصول الى تهدئه الاوضاع يعني
لتمهيد فتره من الهدنه للوصول الى فتره
هدنه للوصول الى ايضا اعاده المفاوضات
الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه هذا من من يعني ما
ترشح بعض المعلومات من هذا الاجتماع على
صعيد اخر العاهل الاردني الملك عبد الله
الثاني التقى قبل قليل بنائب مساعد الرئيس
الامريكي والمنسق
لمنسق البيت الابيض للشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا وشدد في هذا اللقاء العاهل
الاردني على يعني الوصول الى تفاهمات
والوصول الى التهدئه داخل الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وعوده المفاوضات من جديد بين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين هذا من الجانب
الرسمي الاردني المشكله ريم يعني كما
تعلمين يعني الاجتماعات قائمه والحديث
والجهود المبذوله من قبل الاردن ومن قبل
ايضا المجتمع الدولي للوصول الى تفاهمات
لكن على ارض الواقع كيف يتم ترجمه هذه
يعني الاتفاقيات او كيف يتم ترجمه ما حصل
في الاجتماع وما تلخص او ما خلص له ما خلص
له هذا الاجتماع على ارض الواقع يعني كما
تحدثتي قبل قليل بالتزامن مع هذا الاجتماع
قتل مستوطنين اثنين اليوم وبالاضافه الى
ان هناك اجراءات اسرائيليه كانت يعني قبل
ايام في نابلس وتم يعني بهذه الاجراءات
قتل فيها
عشره فلسطينيين بالاضافه الى مئه مصاب كل
هذه التفاصيل يعني كيف يتم الزام اسرائيل
يعني وقف التصعيد داخل الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وكيف يتم الوصول تفاهمات واعاده المفاوضات
الفلسطينيه هذا ما سيخلص له هذا الاجتماع
ان كان هذا الاجتماع يعني قد توصل الى هذه
التفاهمات وان كان هناك ايضا يعني ضمانات
من الجانب الامريكي ومن الجانب ومن جانب
الجانب الدولي لوقف اسرائيل لكل هذا
التصعيد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه بالاضافه
الى ايضا يعني كما نعلم ان رمضان شهر
رمضان على الابواب لذلك هذا الاجتماع يعني
اهميته تكمن اهميته تكمن في انه قبل شهر
رمضان بايام حيث في هذا الشهر الفضيل
تزداد وتيره التصعيد وازداد التوتر في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه نعم في رمضان من السنه
السابقه كانت هناك احداث المسجد الاقصى
ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر عماد على ان نعود
لك في نشراتنا القادمه لفهم ما يرشح عن
هذا الاجتماع من العقبه مراسل العربيه
عماد العضايله شكرا جزيلا
الى ملفنا اخر الان من ايران حيث اعلن
وزير الخارجيه الاسباني خصام نويل اعلن
الافراج عن الاسبانيه انا بنيرا المسجونه
في ايران منذ نهايه العام 2022 وقال
الباريس ان المعتقل الاسبانيه في ايران
افرج عنها السبت وتم نقلها جوا الى مدريد
في ايراننا ايضا هبطت العمله الايرانيه
الى ادنى مستوى امام الدولار في السوق غير
الرسميه اليوم مع تزايد عزله ايران بسبب
برنامجها النووي وانتهاكها لحقوق الانسان
وامدادها روسيا بطائرات مسيره وسجل
الدولار حوالي 600 ريال في السوق
الايرانيه غير الرسميه بالمقارنه مع 575
الف ريال امس و540 الف ريال اول امس
الجمعه والقت السلطات الايرانيه باللون في
تدني قمه العمله على ما اسمته مكيده
الاعداء لزعزعه استقرار الدوله بعد اشهر
من الاضطرابات التي اشعلتها وفاه ماسه
اميني وهي
رهن احتجاز الشرطه في منتصف سبتمبر الماضي
ومع تسجيل العمله المحليه انهيارا غير
مسبوق يتنمى غضب عمالي جراء تدني الاجور
على وقع ارتفاع نسب التضخم السنوي عضو
مجلس اداره مركز مجالس العمل الايراني علي
اصلاني حذر من المماطله في رفع الاجور
واعتبر اصلان ان نسبه الزياده التي تنوي
حكومه ابراهيم رئيس تطبيقها والتي حددت ب
25% لا تتناسب مع ارتفاع الاسعار ياتي ذلك
فيما حضر مراقبون من ان العمال سيواجهون
قريبا مشاكل عده في توفير المواد الغذائيه
الاساسيه اذا لم تتراجع الحكومه عن خطتها
بشان تعديل اجور الموظفين وتشهد ايران منذ
فتره ازمه اقتصاديه حيث تجاوز التضخم
الشهري الخمسين بالمئه فيما تفاقم عجل
الميزانيه وهو منعكس على الاوضاع المعيشيه
للكثيرين ما دفع البعض للمشاركه في
الاحتجاجات المستمره في البلاد منذ مقتل
الفتاه الكرديه مساء امين حيث مددوا بخطط
الحكومه على الصعيد الاقتصادي وندد كذلك
بالاوضاع المعيشيه
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
[تصفيق]
اهلا بك معنا الى نشره الخامسه استاذ
مسعود كما تعلم حضرتك هذه الاحتجاجات
العماليه تعيش ايران بين الفتره والاخرى
احتجاجات المتقاعدين كذلك ولكن ان تاتي
هذه الاحتجاجات في فتره تشهد فيها ايران
اصلا عمليه احتقان في الداخل بعد وفاه
ماسه امينه وهناك تصعيد لم يتوقف ولم يهدا
فما الذي يمكن ان تعنيه
تحياتي لك والمشاهدي الكرام اهلا بك بلا
شك هذا كان من المتوقع عندما تخف
الاحتجاجات
الاجتماعيه والسياسيه ستاتي الاحتجاجات
المطلبيه الاحتجاجات المطلبيه مرتبطه
بالوضع الاقتصادي
المتازم في داخل ايران والذي يزداد يوما
بعد يوم ازمه وتفاقما نتيجه
للسياسات الداخليه في التعاطي مع
المواطنين والسياسات الخارجيه التي
تمارسها ايران على الصعيد الخارجي لو
سمعنا يوم امس
قائد القوه الجويه في الحرس الثوري
الايراني كان يهدد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يهدد بضرب قواعد امريكا وايران
استطاعت ان تنتج صاروخ قد يبلغ مدى حوالي
2000 كيلومتر كل هذه الامور تؤثر بلا شك
على الوضع الاقتصادي الايراني بسب فقدان
الثقه بعلاقات ايران الدوليه عندما تلجا
دوله الى لغه التهديد هناك ادوات التاثير
اللااراديه قد لا تكون الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قررت تنزل السعر الدولار ولكن
عندما يقوم مسؤول عسكري رفيع المستوى يهدد
دول اخرى ويهدد قواعد امريكا انا بلا شك
يؤثر على سعر العمله في الداخل ولكن استاذ
مسعود هذه التصريحات الايرانيه التي تهدد
من خلالها الغرب وتعتبر اكثر من ذلك ايران
تعتبر بان انخفاض سعر عملتها يعود الى ما
اسمته مكيده العدو هل تعتقد بان هذه
التصريحات هي موجهه بالاساس للداخل
الايراني او هناك رساله اخرى
للمجموعه الدوليه من خلال هكذا تعبير
هذه التهديدات لها وجهتين وجهه داخليه
ووجهه خارجيه وجهه داخليه حتى تظهر يظهر
النظام بانه نظام قوي ومتراص وبامكانه
تجاوز كل هذه الامور ورغم ان
التهديدات تحاك ضده والمؤامرات تحاك ضده
الا انه قوي ويستطيع تجاوزها حتى يعطي
للمحتج في الداخل والمعارض بالداخل بانكم
لم ولن تستطيعوا اسقاط هذا النظام وفي نفس
الوقت يبعثون الرساله الى العالم خاصه
الدول الغربيه التي اوقفت
التفاوض مع ايران حول الملف النووي بان
البديل في حاله عدم استئناف المفاوضات
وبالتالي
ايصالها الى نتيجه وهي الغاء العقوبات
الاقتصاديه على ايران سيكون البديل هو
الصواريخ والمسيرات
والتهديدات على كل سيبقى الموضوع محل
متابعه ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر مسعود مع
شكر جزيل الشكر على المشاركه من دبي صحفي
المختص في شان الايراني مسعود الفك شكرا
لك
[موسيقى]
وفي تدعيه الازمه الانسانيه في سوريا
والتي خلفها الزلزال المدمر في السادس من
فبراير الماضي هبطت طائره تابعه للاتحاد
الاوروبي في مطار الدمش قد وليلي تتضمن
مساعدات من الخيام ومعدات الايواء
والتدفئه وقالت المفوضيه الاوروبيه في
بيان لها ان طائره مساعدات الجديده هي جزء
من سلسله رحلات نشويه تنقل المساعدات من
الدول الاوروبيه الى الشعب السوري في كل
من المناطق التي تسيطر عليها الحكومه
والخارجه كذلك عن سيارتها
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الشان الليبيه الان حيث افادت
وسائل اعلام الليبيه عن تاجيل جلسه المجلس
الاعلى المقرر عقدها اليوم لرفض اغلبيه
اعضاء المجلس شروط الترشح لرئاسه الوارده
في التعديل الدستوري الثالث عشر المقترح
من مجلس النواب جاء هذا التصريح على لسان
عضو المجلس الاعلى للدوله امينه المحجوب
وكانت وسائل اعلام الليبيه نسبت الى رئيس
المجلس الاعلى للدوله خالد المشري تائده
لتعطيل الدستوريه الثالث عشر الذي اصدره
البرلمان في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر وقال
المشري ان المخاوف من ان وجود نظام
الرئاسي يولد ديكتاتورا جديدا لا مبرر له
لان اختصاصاته مقيده
الى موضوع اخر حيث اعلن حرس الحدود
الايطالي مصرع 58 وانقذ ما يقرب من مئه
اخرين في حادثه غرق مركبا للمهاجرين قباله
السواحل الايطاليه وبحسب مسؤول ايطالي فان
القارب انطلق من تركيا وكان يقل افغانا
وباكستانيين وصوماليين وانه وفقا لشهادات
الناجين كان على متنه نحو 150 شخصا هذا
فيما اعرب رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا
عن اسفها العميق واكدت التزام الحكومه
بوقف الهجره البحريه غير النظاميه لمنع
المزيد من الماسي بحسب قولها
مشاهدينا قبل المتابعه نشير فقط الى عاجل
كونان نتابعه منذ قليل اسفل الشاشه 250
عضوا في البرلمان البريطاني واقعون بيانا
يدعم احتجاجات وخطه المعارضه احتجاجات
ايران وخطه المعارضه الى فاصل من بعده
سنعود لنتابع تويتر تنفذ ثمن جوله تسريح
باقاله العشرات من موظفيها وسط مساء
لتعويض انخفاض الايرادات
نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد في ظهورها الخامس
حضرت ابنه زعيم الكوريه الشمالي كيم جونغ
اون مراسم تبشين لاحد مشاريع البنيه
التحتيه بالعاصمه ولم تذكر وكاله الانباء
الكوريه المركزيه وهي ابنه او لم تذكر هذه
الفتاه اسمها جو اي وهي ابنه كيم جون اون
ولكنها اشارت اليها باسم ابنه كيم
المحبوبه ومع ظهور جوي المتكرر يرجح خبراء
بان زعيم الكوريه الشمالي يعد ابنته
الصغيره للسلطان من بعده في تقليد نادر
الحدوث
هل ابنه الزعيم كوريا الشماليه وريثته
القادمه لعرش بيون جانج فقد لوحظ ان كيم
جونغ اون كشف من ظهور ابنته كيم جو اي
للعالم
على الرغم من ندره المعلومات حول الفتاه
يعتقد انها تبلغ من العمر 11 عاما كيم جوي
اي هي ثاني مولود لزعيم كوريا الشماليه
والتي خطفت الاضواء بالصوره الدعائيه
الاخيره وفي وقت سابق من فبراير شوهدت
تجلس جنبا الى جنب مع والدها في عرض عسكري
مكان لا يجلس فيه اي شخص بلا منصب او
مكانه الرفيعه وفي الاسبوع الماضي تم نشر
صور لها وهي تحضر مادبه رسميه الى جانب
الجنرالات المزينين بالميداليات كما تم
تصوير ابنه الزعيم الصبيه كيم جوي اوي
مؤخرا وهي تصفق للاعبين في احدى مبارات
كره القدم في عطله وطنيه وهكذا قويه
التكهنات بان كيم جون جون ربما يعد ابنته
لتاخذ مكانه في حدث سيكون غير مسبوق في
تاريخ كوريا الشماليه فالبلاد لم تشهد
قاعدته امراه من قبل
لكن زعيم الكوري الشمالي ابدى استعداده
لوضع النساء في مناصب في السلطه وقد عين
كيم بالفعل نساء في المناصب الابرز في
نظامه مثل شقيقته كيميو جونغواي التي كان
لها ظهور قوي في فتره سابقه والتي مثلت
كوريا الشماليه على الساحه العالميه في
دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه الشتويه كما ان
تشويسون تشغل منصبه وزير خارجيه كوريا
الشماليه
[موسيقى]
الى افغانستان الان وهناكب المتابعون ما
اذا كانت حكومه طالبان ستتراجع عن القيود
التي فرضتها على الفتيات الرغبات في
التعلم مع اعاده فتح المدارس الثانويه
الشهر المقبل وبعد 550 يوما من اجبار
الفتيات على البقاء في المنزل يضع تقرير
لصحيفه تايمز املا في اخر النفق الذي
بداته طالبان بتصعيدها ضد المراه تدريجيا
منذ الاطلاع على الحكم في اغسطس من سنه
2021 فلم يقتصر الامر على منع الفتيات من
الالتحاق بالمدارس المتوسطه وثانويه اذ
امتد ليشمل الجامعات وحظرهن من المجيء الى
اصلاه الرياضيه والحدائق العامه فضلا عن
منعهن من السفر بدون مرافقه الذكور ترى
التايمز البريطانيه ان الانقسامات غير
المسبوقه كما وصفتها بين قياده طالبان
بشان تعليم الفتيات اثار بعض الامل في
التغيير هذه الامال تصدم بافكار زعيم
الحركه او تصطدم بافكار زعيم الحركه هبه
الله اخ زاده التي تصفه الصحيفه بالرجل
الغامض حيث يرى بحسب خبراء ان منحى النساء
حقوقهن سوف يقوض سلطه جماعته وتختلف
طالبان التي يقودها خنزدى عن تلك التي
اعتلت السلطه في التسعينات بقياده زعيمها
ومؤسسها الراحل محمد عمر حيث تشهد الان
وجود اجنحه وفصائل داخلها فهناك المتشددون
الذين يدعمهم زاد وثمه فريق اخر اكثر
برغماتيه تقول الصحيفه ان هناك املا في
مقاومه ناعمه داخل الحركه نفسها لقرارات
زاد حيث يتم بالفعل تحدي حظر التعليم
بهدوء اذ يسمح قاده طالبان المحليون
بالمدارس المجتمعيه غير النظاميه او يغضون
الط رف عن المدارس السريه
نتابع هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من الرياضه
صحفي الافغاني احمد السيد سيد احمد اهلا
بك معنا هل هناك امل ولو بسيط كما تقول
صحيفه البريطانيه في امكانيه تغيير ما
خاصه بعوده البنات او الفتيات الى المدارس
اهلا استاذ ريما هناك يعني كما كما وصفه
المراقبون يعني بان هناك قد يكون احتمال
عوده المدارس الثانويه وحتى المتوسطه
بحلول الشهر القادمه هو يوافق يوم 21 مارس
بدايه السنه الدراسيه والتي تكون مع بدايه
فصل الربيع في افغانستان كل عام لكن هذه
الاحتمالات هي تحدثت بعده مصادر قالوا بان
هناك احتمال سيتم رسم خطه للمواد الدراسيه
وهناك لجنه من عده وزارات وجهات في طالبان
تدرس مساله المناهج الدراسيه خصوصا
للفتيات وحتى للبنين والبنات ولكن هذه
الاحتمالات ضعيفه جدا يعني طالبان لم تغلق
المدارس من اجل ان المناهج مثلا غير
متوافقه مع الشريعه الاسلاميه
احمد ولو انه هذا الموضوع حضرتك تعلم بانه
كان مطروح خاصه مع محاوله حقانها الاقتراب
من المجتمع المدى المجتمع الدولي وطرحه او
على الاقل تمريره لرسائل بالقول باننا
سنتغير هل تعتقد بان هذا الصراع لازال
موجود بين جماعه اخون زاده وجماعه حقاني
وبالتالي قد ينتج عنه شيء
يؤثر على قرار عوده الدراسه من عدمها
حقاني تحدث وحتى انه تحدث الى الدائره
المقربه منه وقال بانه بحلول الربيع اذا
لم يصدر قرار من الزعيمه في مساله تعليم
البنات وحتى مساله عمل الفتيات هو بعض
القرارات واذا لم يتراجع عنها سيتحرك بشكل
علني اكثر لتشكيل التحرك الذي يريد ان
يقوده لمحاوله عدم احتكار السلطه من قبل
زعيم طالبان لكن المساله المهمه مجلس
الوزراء وبعض الوزراء في طالبان وكبار
العلماء هي ارسلوا خطاب او رساله الى زعيم
طالبان الملهبه الله ارسلوا له الرساله
لانهم لا يستطيعون اللقاء منذ عده اشهر
يرفض لقاء القاده المنفتحين الغرب عندما
ارسل لهم هذه ارسلوا له هذه الرساله بانه
يريدون ان يعيد النظر في هذه القرارات
تحدث
هبه الله رد عليهم قائلا اذا اتيتم لي
واثبتم بان هناك
[موسيقى]
دليله ونص شرعي يسمح للفتيات فوق سنه 12
بالخروج من المنزل سوف اسمح للفتيات
بالعمل والتعليم نعم
يقصد الخروج من المنزل وليس الدراسه يقول
اذا كان الاعمار الفتيات فوق 12 سنه هل
يسمح لهم بالخروج من المنزل او لا هذا
يظهر يؤكده بان المدارس الثانويه المتوسطه
وحتى الجامعات اغلقت ما عدا المدارس
الابتدائيه وحتى المدارس الدينيه للفتيات
فوق سن 12 مغلقه
احمد ان كان هناك محاوله لتغيير المناهج
الدراسيه كما تفضلت بالاشاره او هناك لغه
يحاول طالبان ترويجها للمجتمع الدولي لا
غير اود شكرا جزيل الشكر احمد السيد
الصحفي الافغاني كنت معنا من الرياض شكرا
لك
[موسيقى]
الى موضوع عنا اخر الان حيث تحدثت صحيفه
وولد عن تقرير امريكي رسمي يشير الى ان
فيروس كورونا تسرب من مختبر في الصين كما
استبعد التقرير الامريكي ان يكون تسرب
كورونا او تسرب كورونا نتيجه برنامج عسكري
بيولوجي صيني وقالت صحيفه هوستيجونال ان
المسؤولين الامريكيين رفضوا الادلاء
بتفاصيل بشان المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
والتحليلات الجديده التي شاركت بها وزاره
الطاقه ودفعتها الى تغيير موقفها
وفي سياق اخر افاد تقرير صادر عن المراكز
الامريكيه لمكافحه الامراض والوقايه عن
وفاه اكثر من 18 الف شخص بسبب الانفلونزا
في البلاد هذا الموسم واضاف التقرير ان
200 الف مريض دخل المستشفيات من اصل 25
مليون مصاب واوصى مركز السيطره على
الامراض بالتطعيم السنوي ضد الانفلونزا
لكل شخص يبلغ من العمر سته اشهر او اكثر
في بريطانيا تسبب نقص الفواكه والخضروات
المستورده باجبار المتاجر الكبرى على فرض
قيود على المشتريات مثل تحديد الكميه التي
يتم بيعها لكل عميل وسط تحضير المزارعين
وتجار التجزئه من تفاقم الوضع في ظل
انخفاض الانتاج المحلي وتحذر تقارير محليه
من ان الازمه قد تستمر الى نهايه شهر
ابريل المقبل الى ان يبدا الانتاج المحلي
من تلك الخضروات من نزول الى السوق
يبدو ان الامر سيستمر لاسبوعين اخرين فقط
قد لا تحتاج للمزيد من الطماطم لكن اذا
كانت لديك عائله كبيره فالامر سيختلف
الاسعار ارتفعت بسرعه وشده هذا واقع ومن
السخف تجاهله
بصراحه اختار السرعه الارخص حاليا بسبب
التضخم وتكلفه المعيشه الامر مخيف للغايه
نامل ان يتم اصلاح الوضع قريبا
اكد مجموعه من الباحثين البريطانيين
التابعين لشركه الابحاث البريطانيه
اوتونومي ان تقليص الايام ايام العمل يعزز
رفاهيه الموظفين كما يساهم في الحفاظ على
الانتاجيه
تخفيض ايام العمل من خمسه الى اربعه في
الاسبوع من اكثر الامنيات رواجا عند
العاملين دراسه جديده موسعه كشفت ما يمكن
ان تحققه تلك الامنيه من نتائج ايجابيه في
حال تنفيذها الدراسه قامت بها شركه
الابحاث البريطانيه اوتونومي وشملت احدى
الستين شركه وحوالي 2900 عامل في بريطانيا
العمل لمده اربعه ايام فقط يعزز رفاهيه
الموظفين ويزيد من الانتاجيه وفق الدراسه
كما يساهم في انخفاض مستويات القلق والتعب
والتحسن الصحه العقليه والجسديه العمل
لمده اربعه ايام اد ى لموازنه العمل مع
الالتزامات الاجتماعيه بنسبه
54%
56 شركه من اصل 61 بنسبه
92% قالت انها مستمره في نظام اربعه ايام
في الاسبوع
90% من الموظفين ابدوا رغبتهم في استمرار
العمل باربعه ايام اسبوعيا
من الموظفين افادوا بزياده قدرتهم على
العمل
ذكر تقرير لموقع
الالكتروني ان شركه تويتر المملوكه
للملياردير ايلون ماسك صرحت عشرات
الموظفين في اطار ثامن جولات تخفيض
العماله منذ ان تولى ماسك رئاسه شبكه
التواصل الاجتماعي الشهيره اواخر اكتوبر
ونقل التقرير عن اشخاص على درايه مباشره
بهذه المساله في وقت مبكر قولهم ان تخفيض
الوظائف جميله العديد من الفرق الهندسيه
مشيرا الى ان خفض الوظائف الاخير يستهدف
تعويضا انخفاض الايرادات التي تقلصت
بالفعل 70% على الاقل ليصل الى حوالي 2000
موظف
وفي الولايات المتحده ايضا وثقت صور تساقط
كثيف للثلوج على جنوب ولايه كاليفورنيا
خلال عاصفه ثلجيه حول لوس انجلوس بينما
تهدد امطار غزيره مناطقه اخرى بفيضانات
نتابع
[موسيقى]
الخامس انتهت لليوم نعود القاكم في نقاش
بانوراما لهذا المساء اخبارنا دائما
مستمره على مدار اليوم وعلى العربيه
دوتنات للمزيد دائما العربيه دوت نايت
ويمكنكم مسح الكود الظاهر على الشاشه
للمزيد من التفاصيل ومتابعه هذه الاخبار
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]